So, do you like living in the country or in the city?
I like to live in the city.
Why?
The city is exciting!
It has more culture than the country.
There are many museums and restaurants.
Every night, there's theater and music...
...and there are more jobs.
That is why I'm here.
Well, I agree.
There is more culture in the city and there might be more jobs.
But the country has more nature!
It's peaceful and beautiful.
There are more trees and mountains.
The air is clean.
You can go hiking and camping.
The city is not beautiful.
It's noisy and dirty.
I disagree.
I think all the different buildings are beautiful.
And I like to watch all the different people.